yeah what do you guys think of this
colby covington rd a fight this time
jack for that Jack I hope our DA busts
him up well Kobey's doing what you said
you wanted yeah yeah talking a lot of
[ __ ] and getting a lot of people I feel
like he's doing I don't know I don't
know he's doing what he's doing it's
creating people paying attention look
for sure he beat Maya which is a huge
accomplishment right Maya is still an Al
absolutely world-class fighter but other
than that really hasn't beaten big-name
guys and he's fighting for the interim
title you got to think that a lot of
that is because he's been very smart
with promotion tell you had it oh yeah
man that's good that's good I don't have
anybody man I'm in that same what we
just said what the [ __ ] knows like I
like the matchup though because Colby
first of all Kobe's not making 155
unless he cuts a [ __ ] leg off right
he's a bigger guy our da was the
155-pound champion so you have to think
Kobe's gonna have a size advantage
Kobe's a very good wrestler he's
relentless and he managed to do
something that very few people been able
to do with Maya where he just
overwhelmed them beat him up beat him up
standing controlled where the fight took
place when a clear-cut decision did it
in Brazil and did it after Woodley did
it and did it arguably better than
Woodley did it you know he was on top of
Maya
he wasn't avoiding him in the way that
would lead it'd but Woodley was injured
in that fight he hurt his shoulder like
in the first round but it was an
impressive performance I mean if you go
back and watch what Maya was able to do
with like Ric story what Maya has been
able to do with Matt Brown my is a
[ __ ] monster when he gets ahold of you
it's such next-level jujitsu and Kobe
was really never in trouble in that
fight so you have to look at that and
you go okay well obviously he has
fantastic defense solid wrestling base
can strike on the feet and knows how to
like knows how to fight a grimy nasty
fight and he's the bigger guy but then
you look at our da and our da at light
weight was a [ __ ] mauler was just
Merkin people right but then you look at
him at welterweight knew like Jesus he
might be better at welterweight look how
good he looked against Neil Magny
everybody struggles with Neil Magny he
smashed Neil Magny
took him down to leg kicked him dropped
a
get on top of them strangle him I mean
beat the [ __ ] out of Robbie Lawler that
Robbie Lawler fight was crazy yeah like
he just overwhelmed one of the best
strikers in the welterweight division
overwhelmed him from the outside with
angles and technique Fogg do so yeah
it's interesting man it's very very
interesting it's very interesting
I'm so mad Rd and Conor never fought I
know I was so jacked for that I was
almost exciting I was so excited for
that fight broke his [ __ ] phone you
know he's gonna be a problem for a lot
of people is that Greg Urgell SP oh yeah
[ __ ] dude yeah and pretty quiet
foxing four-time all-american want one
time national champ sugar tougher and
[ __ ] no hole last weekend yeah I was
there [ __ ] getting better well
way better
55 yeah he's getting better he's a beast
yeah dude he's